[Música]
fue un discurso muy esperado
46 años después de que marruecos tomara
el control de la mayor parte del sáhara
occidental el rey mohamed sexto se
muestra firme para el la soberanía de su
reino sobre este territorio en disputa
no está en duda
para marruecos su sáhara no es
negociable hoy como en el pasado el
sáhara marroquí nunca estará en la
agenda de ninguna negociación
ya sea por la historia la legitimidad la
firme voluntad del pueblo marroquí o el
amplio reconocimiento de la comunidad
internacional minaya walter haciendo
blind western
hoy en día el 80% del territorio de esta
antigua colonia española está controlado
por marruecos pero ningún acuerdo final
ha fijado su estatus en piedra rabat
propone una amplia autonomía bajo su
soberanía pero el frente polisario un
grupo armado local respaldado por
argelia lucha por la independencia de la
región los debates sobre el sáhara están
alimentando un importante conflicto
entre rabat y argel y el discurso del
monarca llega en un momento en el que
las relaciones están en su punto más
bajo esta semana las tensiones han
vuelto a aumentar después de que argel a
gustar a rabat e haber matado a tres
camioneros argelinos durante un atentado
en el sáhara occidental' pero el clima
está candente desde hace un año tras una
decisión repentina de la pasada
administración estadounidense de donald
trump que reconoció la soberanía
marroquí sobre el territorio mientras
que naciones unidas sigue pidiendo un
referendo de autodeterminación